how did you first become aware of their
nose when did you first hear the name
Elizabeth Holmes
well she had rocketed to fame arguably
about a year prior in 2000 or 2014 and
then at the end of that year late 2014
I read a profile of Elizabeth Holmes and
the New Yorker magazine on my way home
from work
in in Manhattan to Brooklyn on the
subway and I read the story with
interest but thought immediately thought
there's something off about this and and
the main thing I thought was off was
this notion that this 19 year old
college dropout you know had left
Stanford with just a semester or two of
Chemical Engineering under her belt and
gone on to to pioneer and to develop
groundbreaking new medical science I I
didn't think that was possible I know
that there's a history of that happening
in Silicon Valley in computers you know
Mark Zuckerberg legend has it taught
himself how to code on his dad he
dropped out of Harvard like Bill Gates
right and Bill Gates three decades
before him and and they were self-taught
programmers and they built companies
that were you know in the tradition of
computer software I mean hit in
Zuckerberg space it was Facebook and it
was a website but it's traditional tech
and medicine is different you know
medicine you usually need to go to
medical school and often scientist
medical scientists get PhDs and do
postdoctoral complex it's complex and
Union not only do you need this formal
training but you often need to do years
if not decades of research to add value
and as I say in the book there's a
reason that most Nobel scientists and
medicine win their prizes in their 60s
right takes a lifetime of work to really
break through and so that made me feel
skeptical from that from the get-go and
then are you a skeptical guy generally
is that like the training and journalism
is to read stuff and say but what if I'm
a pretty skeptical guy yeah where does
that come from you
I I don't know I just always a my mom's
in New Yorker and I yeah and I sort of
grew up in New York I grew up in in
Paris during the school year and the
summers in New York but no I've always
had a good [ __ ] detector I feel like
I've always been a good judge of
character I think it's a skill that
comes in handy when you're a reporter
for sure and you know my whole career as
a journalist had been mostly
investigative journalism and
hard-hitting stories raising questions
and you know to be fair after that New
Yorker story I might not have done
anything with that hunch if it hadn't
been for the fact that a couple weeks
later I got a tip a tip right Wow and
now you have a Pulitzer by the way for
the record right yeah I've been part of
a couple teams at the journal who've won
Pulitzer is the latest one was in 2015
for a series that we had done on
Medicare fraud and abuse and actually
during the reporting of that series I
had encountered the tipster huh a
practicing pathologist in the Midwest
who moonlighted as the writer of an
obscure blog called the pathology blog
which he spelled DL a WG and he had seen
the New Yorker story too and knowing a
thing or two about blood testing was
immediately skeptical wrote a skeptical
blog item about it and then I was
quickly contacted by this little band of
ther no skeptics one of whom was a guy
by the name of Richard fuse who was a
childhood neighbor of Elizabeth Holmes's
family back when they lived in
Washington DC in the 80s and and who had
patented a patent that had caused
Elizabeth to sue him so he had been
involved in litigation with Elizabeth
Holmes and and during those three years
of litigation had become convinced that
their nose was a scam he was a medical
doctor by training right and friends
with the family as you go into the book
right he would buy the mine and let them
stay at his house right and and he was
may never contacted him about fairness
he felt hurt his pride was hurt when she
dropped out of Stanford and created this
company the
was gonna do a medical product because
that was all his that was his whole
expertise and he felt like she knew that
the parents knew it and yet they didn't
come to him for advice and so stung in
his pride he then you know listen to
this interview she'd given in 2005 and
NPR looked at her website thought that
her vision had merit and figured out a
part of the vision that she hadn't
patented and patented it himself well
and it was basically a mechanism to
alert doctors when the blood test
results are abnormal hmm and she had
then found out several years later about
his patent and developed this theory
that his son who had worked at the law
firm that their nose had initially
employed tafolla yeah that her
allegation was that the the son of
Richard fuse had stolen her provisional
patents funneled them to his father and
that he had then used that information
to file his own patent which after a lot
of reporting and looking at the legal
record I found to be completely untrue
and fabricated nevertheless she had sued
him he had been involved in litigation
with her for three years and and had
become convinced that the whole company
was built on a scaffolding of fraud and
it so happened that he had just made
contact with a former tharros employee
who had just left the company who had
been in a crucial position which was
that of laboratory director and who knew
exactly where the bodies were buried so
when the pathology blogger contacted me
told me about Richard fuse I talked to
Richard fuse and then I heard there is a
primary source out there who knows
things
and who's alleging all manner of
wrongdoers pricked up Wow and I said you
know this is a story right and it could
be a big one